You mean staring at each other's, looking into each other's eyes?
Doesn't seem natural.
Four minutes is a long time.
No other instructions?
No, I have to look in your eyes.
Yeah, that's it?
That's it.
How did you feel?
Weird.
In 55 years of marriage, we've never really looked into each other's eyes like that.
But I do look at your eyes sometimes 'cause I'm checking your blood sugar.
You check on me all the time.
Yeah.
I wondered what you were thinking.
How wonderful it was to just sit here and look at my wife for a change.
Without discussing work, business and situations.
When I look at you really closely, I realize how much I need you and what you mean to me.
And because that's the truth.
And I couldn't imagine being with anybody else.